[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de pourvu que ça dure les missions qui
rend les co-responsables sur public
sénat aujourd'hui on va s'intéresser aux
banques car elles n'ont jamais été
confronté à autant de défis en même
temps à commencer par une pression de la
concurrence notamment celle des banques
digital qui séduisent de plus en plus de
français sans compter la petty et des
gaffes à qui tentent quelques incursions
dans les services bancaires vous verrez
et puis le secteur bancaire est l'un des
plus réglementés sans oublier les
faibles taux d'intérêt qui réduisent
leurs marges à leur métier de banquier
doit-il se réinventer pour assurer sa
pérennité on posera la question à
laurent mignon le président du groupe
banque populaire caisse d'epargne mais
d'abord focus sur ces acteurs numériques
qui cherche à détrôner nos banques
traditionnelles manuel r
[Musique]
3 markets
sébastien 36 ans vient de monter une
petite affaire aux portes de paris à
montrouge jean p
des plats cuisinés à emporter un rictus
la boisson et
sébastien début de sa journée aux
aurores et finit à 23 heures dans la
restauration c'est toujours du gauche
course courte afin que normalement ce
qui lui laisse peu de temps pour gérer
les livraisons la paperasse et ses
comptes en banque
entre deux clients chantre effectué un
virement parce que je suis obligé de le
faire
de gérer mon administratif sur mon
téléphone j'ai accès à tous c'est une
banque en ligne donc c'est simple c'est
rapide ça correspond à mon planning à
moi il y a deux ans sébastien hésite à
quitter sa banque de quartier pour un
établissement entièrement en ligne
aujourd'hui il ne regrette rien c'était
dans une banque traditionnelle va me
coûter 350 euros par an de frais
bancaires pour avoir une carte et un
compte chez eux aujourd'hui ma vente en
ligne ne coûte rien je serai toutes mes
opérations à distance et auquel cas si
j'ai besoin je peux appeler sur les
amplitudes horaires beaucoup plus large
que celle d'une bande un conseiller
compétents et qui va traiter mon
opération si je ne peux pas la faire à
la distance jeu tout à y gagner sur tous
les ports
ces dernières années le paysage bancaire
français se métamorphose la plupart des
établissements traditionnels tiennent le
marché depuis près d'un siècle
mais aujourd'hui ils font face à de
nouveaux acteurs prêts à dépoussiérer le
secteur
aujourd'hui 4 millions et demi de
français ont leurs comptes dans des
banques exclusivement en ligne comme
boursorama bforbank oui ng et ce n'est
pas tout de nouveaux établissements
appelée neo banques apparaissent chaque
jour comme 26 révolus ou encore max qui
n'a pas quatre ans d'ancienneté qui se
cache derrière ces nouveaux
établissements ces banques permettent
elles vraiment de faire des économies
donc des frais bancaires par an en
france et 200 euros tous les ans chez
boursorama c'est moins de 10 euros
vous avez une économie juste sur la
partie banque au quotidien votre carte
de crédit vos chéquiers votre compte
courant qui est divisé par 20 c'est
simple c'est un modèle économique
différent et le client et gagnent en
pouvoir d'achat l'objectif de cette
banque en ligne est d'atteindre plus de
4 millions de clients en 2023 ces
chiffres donnent le vertige et des idées
à d'autres investisseurs de plus en plus
donné aux banques apparaissent difficile
de s'y retrouver c'est simple rapide des
finances n'ont jamais été aussi bien
organisée la plus connue est n 26 avec 2
millions de clients en france mais cet
établissement n'offrent pas les mêmes
services que les banques traditionnelles
impossible d'obtenir un prêt immobilier
par exemple quels sont les statuts de
ces nouveaux établissements
ont-ils les mêmes garanties que les
banques traditionnelles pas forcément
quand on est consommateur il faut
vérifier le statut d'établissement si
c'est un établissement de crédit aucune
banque ou c'est un établissement de
paiement ou de monnaie électronique si
c'est un établissement de crédit ce
qu'on appelle une vraie banque entre
guillemets
et on est garantie d'avoir de récupérer
100 mille cinq cent mille euros de ces
fous des côtes garantie à 100 mille
euros en cas de faillite et toujours
plus de services il ya dans le monde un
nouvel acteur qui se créent tous les
mois pour proposer du service financier
de banque au quotidien plutôt autour du
paiement on sait pas encore la manière
dont ils vont évoluer en terme de
rentabilité de profitabilité ya une
réelle interrogation sur dans quelques
années combien d'acteurs resteront parmi
les néo banques on trouve green got un
établissement de paiement qui prend soin
de la planète c'est le défi un peu fou
que s'est lancé mode gaillot du haut de
ses 27 dans
l autre monde très contente de vous voir
en drap au niveau des investissements
est ce qu'on avait accord pour un
premier jet d'encre in fine
aujourd'hui 21 mille clients ont décidé
d'apporter leur confiance à la jeune
entrepreneuse merci à vous toutes et
tous et pia très vite parce
qu'aujourd'hui en fait on le sait que
trop peu mais son argent dans les
banques traditionnelles bah il permet de
financer les énergies fossiles pétrole
gaz charbon et moi je fais partie d'une
génération qui essaye de faire très
attention à son impact sur
l'environnement et je me suis rendu
compte qu'une bail avait pas de solution
pour bat pour nous pour mettre notre
argent ouvert en fait pour faire en
sorte que notre argent ne financent plus
à l'énergie fossile mais finances ce qui
va avec nos valeurs c'est à dire plutôt
les entreprises de la transition bas
carbone
de garantie de réelles placements vers
et rien qu en utilisant la carte
bancaire le client protège
l'environnement vous avez avec nous un
impact au quotidien puisque à chaque
fois que vous payer les frais que le
commerçant payent beaucoup payé par
carte nous les redirige vers des
associations notamment par exemple la
cession de dépollution du plastique dans
les océans on achète aussi des hectares
de forêt primaire au brésil pour les
sauver de la déforestation et on
développe des projets d'énergie
renouvelable
que ce soit les établissements en ligne
des néo banque verte ou pas la
concurrence est rude pour les banques
traditionnelles
68% des français seraient prêts à faire
de ces nouveaux acteurs en ligne leur
banque principale
carte bancaire compte courant crédit à
la consommation non seulement les
banques traditionnelles peuvent se
méfiait des banques digital mais aussi
garder un oeil sur les gaffes qui lorgne
sur une part du gâteau bancaire bonjour
pascal de lima bonjour vous êtes
économiste et prof à sciences po est ce
que c'est de la science fiction parce
qu'en 2050 on peut imaginer que sa
banque s'appelle google alors on a mis
50 on pourra imaginer certes mais faut
quand même bien comprendre pour se
projeter ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui très clairement les gars
femmes ne sont pas dans les crédits
immobiliers ni dans les crédits à la
consommation par an que souverain pas
encore sauf aux états unis et encore
elles sont pas réglementées s'ils
voulaient donc en europe aujourd'hui on
n'est que sur du paiement sans contact
mobile maintenant ce qui est source
d'inquiétude pour les banques
traditionnelles c'est qu'elles ont une
des ambitions complètement folle en fait
et puis elles ont une trésorerie
considérables et donc c'est trésorerie
et leurs ambitions faut savoir que
alphabet la société mère de google
depuis 2000 a lancé plus de 43 projets
dans le domaine du de l'octroi de
crédits dans le domaine de la cyber
sécurité bref c'est des projets tous les
jours avec des films tech et donc ça
fait craindre quand même une arrivée
progressive des gars femmes sur les
marchés bancaires traditionnels des
charrues c'est à dire sur les marchés
américains on voit beaucoup de choses
aucun gaffe à ne fait du crédit pour le
prix immobiliers pour le moment mais
c'est inéluctable ils ont avancé leurs
pions vous l'avais dit dans la carte de
crédit le crédit à la conso aux états
unis aux états aux états unis il ya
apple paix pour les paiements mais il ya
aussi des crédits
comment dire la possibilité d'étaler les
paiements sur les produits sur les
produits apple il y à il y as où les
défis financement locatif également il
faut faut-il rappeler qu'apple en france
fait avec le cic notamment des services
de location du leasing comme on dit donc
il ya déjà quand même une première
pénétration sur les marchés financiers
en france
on est qu'aux balbutiements on n'est
qu'au début c'est pas sur des crédits
conso c'est pas sur des crédits
immobiliers ou là certaines est au banc
comme n 26 et révolution beaucoup plus
menaçante mais on commence à gratter un
peu amazon qui accorde des petits prêts
aux pme françaises c'est c'est le début
de quelque chose c'est une attaque
frontale ça aussi alors c'est une
attaque frontale s'est pas encore
réglementé c'est à dire que ces voix là
il faut faire attention il faut quand
même prévenir tout le monde que il faut
être prudent il faut savoir qu amazon
aux etats unis c'est encore plus fort
qu'en europe puisque amazon aux états
unis fait des crédits d'exploitation aux
pme/tpe 1 on a encore un ou encore
avancé un coût d'un coup si vous voulez
bon voilà mais globalement aujourd'hui
il faut bien le rappeler ça reste encore
un prestataire de services de paiement
qui travaillent qui travaillent avec des
banques il atteint qui ne sont pas là
pour nous est ce que dans le fond les
gaffes ivl où ils ne veulent pas être
banquier ce que est ce que les services
bancaires c'est une espèce de relais de
croissance pour eux ou est-ce que ça
sert leur modèle parce que c'est une
façon d'avoir plus d'informations sur
les clients utilisateurs que nous sommes
oui il ya deux sujets il ya la question
du fait que les gars femmes gèrent
énormément de données sur les clients
lorsque vous faites un paiement via
apple paix via google paie en fait vous
fournissez des données considérable via
un peu loi de vous fournissez des
données considérables vous allez au
restaurant vous payer via le web vous
fournissez des données considérables
donc ça leur confère un avantage si vous
voulez par rapport aux banques parce
qu'on dit que les banques détiennent
deux cents en données moralité en deux
ans les gars femmes peuvent détenir le
même nombre de données donc les
avantages dont un est une menace pour
les banques c'est pas une menace
imminente pour nos banques européennes
c'est pas une menace imminente mais
cependant du fait de cette gestion
données du fait de ce qu'on observe aux
etats unis du fait de leurs ambitions
les connaît leur puissance finances et
de leur puissance financière il ya
réellement une menace faut-il comparer
la capitalisation quand même des dégâts
femmes 5300 milliards c'est pratiquement
voilà le pib c'est plus que le pib des
pays-bas si vous voulez hein donc c'est
quand même quelque chose assez hélas est
considérable pour l'instant garder
partenariat entre les banques
américaines on situe aux états unis et
les gaffes à apple a passé un accord
avec avec goldman sachs google avec
citigroup donc pour on n'est pas au
stade de la guerre mais du partenariat
on est au stade du partenariat parce
qu'il faut bien comprendre que les gars
femme ça reste quand même de la
technologie mais en face il ya le métier
est aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs je pense
d'ailleurs à très court terme le métier
ça reste encore dans la banque on peut
pas n'est pas je gère pas des crédits
ont géré pas le risque bancaire du jour
au lendemain avec uniquement des
applications ce que pour résumer
finalement ce sont des applications
c'est de la technologie par contre il y
à des partenariats qui commence à se
tisser entre eux gars femmes et banque
entre bandes et baies aubance conçoivent
les produits qu'ils consomment les
produits qui font la stratégie qui un
jour lui afin voudront peut-être se
passer des banques et avoir la relation
en direct avec le client c'est ça l'idée
c'est de pouvoir avoir la relation
directe ceci dit encore un je pense un
laps de temps important parce qu'elle a
réglementé saint louis qui est
extrêmement contraignantes pour les
banques bien là pour les banques et dans
nos rangs les gars va les gars fin quand
les gars femme voit très bien ce qui se
passe aux etats-unis avec facebook avec
un d'histoire cambridge analytica etc
microsoft et les abus de position
dominante on voit très bien voire très
bien que surtout on ne voit pas d
autorité de tutelle agrémenter les gars
femmes dans les services financiers
comme le font les banques du jour au
lendemain il va falloir attendre encore
un peu mais voilà dans 50 ans quand on
parle du monde du tout techno et du
transhumanisme liées aux métiers de
demain et aux innovations on se demande
pourquoi finalement les gars femme ne
nierai pas beaucoup plus loin dans quoi
je dirais tantôt sur 50 ans oui sur sa
quarante ans oui sur après demain nous
par contre attention et là c'est ce sont
des ses plus des mammouths un peu lent
technologique mais ce sont des hyènes
extrêmement ravi ce sont les néo banques
ce que la n 26 est révolu par contre
sont déjà les établissements de crédit
voilà merci beaucoup en tout cas pas
celle du rubin économiste et professeur
à sciences po
ben justement cette concurrence des
gaffes à des banques digital est ce qu
elle fait vraiment peur aux banques
traditionnelles on va poser la question
au président du groupe banque populaire
caisse d'epargne
les menaces se multiplient tel pour les
banques on en parle avec vous le rend
mignon bonjour bonjour rydzek
installez-vous merci merci président du
groupe bpce banque populaire caisse
d'epargne ont parlé juste avant de
l'incursion des incursions des gaffes à
dans les services bancaires dans le
domaine de la finance notamment
évidemment aux états unis est ce que
vous prenez ces menaces au sérieux au vu
j'ai envie de dire de leur force de
frappe financière de leur savoir faire
technologique ou même pas peur non je
crois qu'il faut prendre ça très au
sérieux les gaffes à comme vous le
soulignez elles ont beaucoup de moyens
financiers elles ont surtout une une
très grande habitude de la relation
client donc c'est des gens à prendre
très au sérieux il faut être concentré
il faut se développer sa propre
stratégie et nous avons des stratégies
digitales importante nous digitalise on
aux banques pour qu'elles puissent
répondre aux attentes des clients nous
le groupe bpce par exemple on a pris une
stratégie assez original qui est de ne
pas vouloir développer une banque
directe une banque une purement digital
on a décidé de digitaliser nos relations
bancaires de toutes nos agences des
caisses d'epargne et des banques
populaires c'est une stratégie qu'on
appelle digital inside et qui fait que
aujourd'hui les applications des banques
populaires les applications des castes
et paris sont parmi les mieux notés du
marché aussi bien que celle d'aider des
nez aux banques on va parler plus
recherchés dont
il faut on voit que apple s'est allié à
goldman sachs pour lancer une carte
bancaire aux états unis là encore une
fois vous associés pour lancer une carte
bancaire avec apple vous dit pourquoi
pas ou fermer la porte n'ont en
l'occurence j'ai pas besoin d'apple pour
développer une carte bancaire donc en
l'occurrence aux etats unis apple s'est
associé avec quelqu'un qui n'est pas une
banque de détail donc s'ils faisaient
ils entreraient dans le marché de la la
concurrence directe avec de beaux je
suis pas sûr que les gaffes à
aujourd'hui et de l'intention de rentrer
dans le marché beaucaire rit-elle en
europe le coeur de notre modèle c'est la
relation client c'est cette proximité
que nous sommes capables de nous et avec
lui grâce à notre proximité de nos
agences de 2 encore une fois caisse
d'épargné banque populaire le rôle du
conseiller qui est demandé par nos
clients on voit d'ailleurs en sortie de
crise les gens souhaitent une proximité
une capacité de dialoguer avec un
conseiller mais il souhaite aussi
pouvoir faire leur banque à distance
aujourd'hui 80 % de nos clients
utilisent des canaux dit gino dort
banque tous les jours et s'accroît
fortement donc il faut pouvoir leur
offrir les deux et appartements monde
fait bien il n'y a pas de raison de
penser que nos modèles sont en danger si
on continue à investir après selon kpmg
68% c'est pas rien des clients seraient
prêts à faire de leur nez aux banques
banques digital leur banque principale
si tous les services bancaires étaient
proposées est ce que à terme quand même
peut-être même rapproché ces banques en
ligne c'est nos banques vont vous faire
de l'ombre elle nous force à vous
présenter à nous exactement elle nous
force à à
elle vous dimanche de laine sur le dos
ou et mais pas tant que ça aujourd'hui
nous gagnons des clients globalement
nous continuons anglais gagner les
clients et donc
elle nous force à nous réinventer elle
nous pousse à penser différemment les
choses et de ce point de vue là c'est
positif moi je vous donne un exemple
pendant la locaux vides qu'est-ce qui
était aux côtés des français pour les
aider qu'est ce qui a aidé des
entreprises françaises à traverser cette
crise c'est lé nos banques non c'était
les banques de proximité c'est nous qui
avons fait des pge qui avons accompagné
les artisans les pros pendant cette
période là c'est pas des néo beau cette
proximité là ses capacités à bien
connaître le besoin du client elle est
indispensable je ne dis pas que les néo
banques peuvent pas apporter de 2,2 à
l'heure et des choses mais pour
l'instant d'abord aucune d'entre elles
n'a démontré un modèle économique viable
et la route probable
et puis on oui mais bon et nous par
ailleurs nous faisons les
investissements pour pouvoir avoir la
même qualité de service que ce qu'elle
offre il ya concurrence des banques
digital en mignon il ya les contraintes
réglementaires faut en parler parce que
quelque part est ce que c'est une aux
banques elles sont réglementées comme
une banque peut l'être on dit qu'être
banquiers et je suis pas là pour vous
plaindre mais dire que c'est beaucoup de
paperasse et beaucoup de fonds propres
assez sûrement beaucoup de fonds propres
c'est
oui j'ai pas la paperasse le non moins
en moins mais c'est beau coup de deux
procédures de vérification vous avez on
nous on doit vraiment nous assurer à
chaque fois qu'on fait des transactions
on peut montrer l'origine des faux
toutes ces choses là qu'on a une très
bonne connaissance de nos clients donc
ça s'appelle know your customer en
anglais toutes ces procédures là sont
des pros c'est sûr qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui très intégrés dans les
processus des grandes banques
probablement pas encore toujours dans
les haubans qui veulent plutôt favoriser
la rapidité de de douves et réprimandes
et est progressivement elles sont
régulés de la même façon et donc ces
sujets là les ratages mais
je crois que nous aujourd'hui le il faut
pas se dire que la régulation est ce qui
va nous protéger comme une barrière nord
à régler une question que j'avais écouté
j'ai de la 2e la devance allez un petit
peu même pas spécialement en tout cas
bien sûr que ça les règlements passé
donc c'est pour ça que les gaffes à
aujourd'hui elle attaque plutôt sur des
services qui sont hors régulation par
exemple les paiements qui est un sujet
ou alors il est régulier mais de façon
beaucoup plus légère et ça c'est un
enjeu très important et le sujet des
paiements est un est un est un est un
débat de deux majeurs deux souverainetés
d'ailleurs pour le pour l'europe des
banques condamnées à se réinventer parce
qu'il ya tout ce qu'on m'a dit las de
cette concurrence le contexte
réglementaire les taux d'intérêt bas on
c'est vrai qu'on va en sortir saron vos
marges d'intérêts ce que le métier de
banquier j'ai pas qu'il est menacé mais
ce qu'il est corseté par tout ça mais
des condamnés à se réinventer moi je
pense que se réinventer c'est toujours
une chance et c'est penser l'avenir
différemment faire progresser son
entreprise faire progresser sa relation
avec les clients et donc en l'occurrence
des aiguillons nous en avons un petit
mot laurent mignon des défis green aussi
qui s'opposent aux banques on l'a vu
dans le reportage en début d'émission
l'émergence de neo banque verte avec
l'engagement que l'argent confié finance
des projets qui sont durables et
responsables est ce que ça aussi c'est
un défi dont des allemands pour les
banques ouais enfin je pense que c'est
un défi pour la société majeur qui est
la transition vers une économie
décarbonée dont on attend les banques
sur ce sujet sûr qu'on attend des
banques comme on attend la société c'est
une évolution majeure ça va pas être
quelque chose de c'est une transition
c'est un matin c'est un monde nouveau
qu'on est en train d'inventer et c'est
pas simplement en finançant quelques
éoliennes que ça va se faire ou en
finançant leurs côtés quelques parcs
photovoltaïques bien on peut calculer
son empreinte carbone quand on est
client de pce jouera ses achats du
quotidien non on peut pas aujourd'hui
mais mais c'est quelque chose qu'on
pourrait faire un jour c'est mais
fondamentalement le gros enjeu il est
beaucoup plus que dans le le caractère
ludique de savoir si ça qu'on change
aussi d'importants maux quotidiens bien
sûr ça fait partie et toutes ces choses
là font partie de ski qui comme on dit
qui concourent à faire progresser la
société vers un monde décarboné mais ce
monde décarboné il va prendre du temps
et le gros enjeu nous avons c'est
accompagner nos clients dans la durée
sur la transition c'est une transition
on va pas passer d'une économie où les
voitures roulent
à l'essence à une économie où elle se
remet tout le monde voilà à l'électrique
pur peut d'ailleurs que cette électrique
étaient des produits de manière qui soit
propre et ça posera d'ailleurs le sujet
la taxonomie européenne de tous qui
derrière et sont des sujets majeurs qui
nécessite beaucoup de travail qui sont
très sérieux dans lequel les
institutions financières doivent
s'engager parce qu'elles ont un rôle en
orientant après les parcs vers ses
finances les défis sont nombreux à
relever pour les banques très nombreux
mais c'est ce qui fait que c'est
passionnant bon très bien merci d'avoir
été avec nous je laurent mignon donc le
président du groupe bpce banque
populaire caisse d'epargne merci merci
beaucoup alors y'a pas que les banques
qui doivent s'engager en faveur de la
protection de la planète nous aussi
clients on a un rôle à jouer focus sur
une appli qui peut nous aider
et cette appli c'est greenlee elle
propose de mesurer l'empreinte carbone
aux achats du quotidien bonjour emilie
jean-david 1 alors l'objectif c'est de
nous aider à changer un petit peu nos
comportements pour les rendre espérons
le plus vertueux serait david quotidien
quand on fait ses courses quand on voit
au resto qu'on regarde sa série préférée
on ne se demande pas si cette dépense à
un coût écologique et pourtant
l'empreinte carbone moyenne des français
revient tenez vous bien à onze de tonnes
de co2 par an selon l'ademe alors
qu'elle devrait tomber à 2 tonnes d'ici
2050 si on veut limiter le réchauffement
de la planète à + 2 degrés donc on est
effectivement et mais il est loin du
compte comment concrètement cette appli
nous aider alors elle à se synchroniser
avec votre banque via une interface
entièrement sécurisé et ça ne prend que
quelques minutes elle a accès à la liste
de toutes vos dépenses la liste de vos
dépenses qu'elle va ensuite décortiqué
j'ai pas trop envie qu'on a accès à mes
comptes pardon alors la pi n'a accès
qu'à votre transaction rassurez vous
mais pas vos identifiants et c'est un
faux évidemment elles s'engagent elles
et à les garder confidentielles
d'ailleurs la cnil a estimé bien que
c'était une bonne élève en matière de
protection des données oui mais on peut
comprendre que certains pour le coup
soient frileux c'est leur compte en
banque quand même alors c'est justement
pour les rassurer que c'est également
adossés à des banques alors il ya par la
bnp et lobant pics paix ou encore only
one vous la retrouvez aussi en marque
blanche sur l'appui de votre banque en
tant que ce soit sur la petite renier ou
sur l'appui de votre banque c'est le
même principe on va scanner vos dépenses
et comment ça se passe justement sauce
calmes alors d'avoir l'appui catégorie
est ce que c'est du loisir est ce que
c'est de l'alimentaire ou est ce que
c'est de la santé par exemple ensuite
elle va convertir sa dépense en g ou en
kilogrammes de co2 émis et vous vous
êtes prêté au jeu oui car je suis prêté
au jeu alors je vous cite quelques
dépenses en israël par exemple mon
panier de courses de 200 euros et bien
il représente 130 kg de co2 émis 1 mon
vélo acheté 150 euros 134 kg de co2 ma
crème de beauté à 30 euros 22 kg de co2
ou encore mon abonnement netflix à 10
euros 17 kg de co2 david vous voyez
l'idée vous avez soufflé le coût
écologique de tout ce que vous dépensez
ça met un petit peu mal à l'aise ça
donne envie de faire un petit peu mieux
quand même pour la planète et pour nous
et des lapinous propose pour chaque
dépense une alternative moins énergivore
type yucca on peut également compenser
nos émissions en finançant des projets
green ou encore en se constitue et
pourquoi pas une cagnotte pour chaque
dépense responsable effectués chez h&m
marques partenaires mais cette appli est
ce qu'elle est capable de traiter toutes
nos dépenses parce que ça reste un
algorithme qui donc a ses limites alors
grigny se dit capable de reconnaître
entre 85 et 89 % de nos transactions
alors dans ce cas particulier bas n'a
pas su reconnaître par exemple à un
panier de courses acheter dans une ferme
en normandie ni mon abonnement à un
quotidien économique donc vous voyez à
quelques petits progrès à faire quand
même une question et milices sur le mode
de calcul comment est ce que ça
fonctionne pour convertir des euros en
kilos de co2 alors la pifé un ratio elle
va prend les émissions de co2 d'un
produit ou d'un service rapporter à
votre ticket de caisse alors vous me
demandez vous ce qu'elles trouvent
toutes ces infos effectivement de co2 eh
bien elle se base sur des données
sérieuses alors ça peut être les données
de l'ademe les données des xi base qui
recense des données macro fiable elle
peut également se baser sur les bilans
rs des entreprises je vous donne un
exemple avec mon vélo que j'ai acheté
chez décathlon fameux de là le fameux
vélo elle s'est basée sur les émissions
de co2 que la société avait publié en
2019 soit 11 milliards de tonnes de co2
elle a donc diviser ce chiffre par le
pris mon vélo mais qu'est ce qui se
passe si ou quand il n'y a aucune info
sur la société ça peut arriver oui alors
dans ces cas là elle va regarder la
moyenne du secteur alors c'est vrai que
c'est plus approximatif mais ça donne
quand même une idée alors exemple avec
mon abonnement netflix a effectivement
l'avait pas de données sur sur le net 6
ha s'est basé sur et bien là le la
moyenne du secteur donc celle du
streaming vidéo à la regarder par
exemple l'empreinte vous savez de ces
gigantesques datacenter qui se trouve en
irlande est ce que tout ça n'est pas un
peu réducteur parce que la somme
dépensée ne dit pas tout de notre
empreinte carbone c'est vrai vous avez
raison à un panier de courses à 50 euros
ne sera pas forcément plus énergivores
qu'un panier à 30 euros mais ce qui est
bien avec cette appli sait qu'on a la
possibilité d'affiner ses dépenses a par
exemple ce qu'il ya dans votre panier si
c'était plutôt de la viande rouge on bat
des légumes bio ça n'a pas la même
empreinte forcément ça marche aussi avec
votre fournisseur d'énergie qui propose
ou ne propose pas d'énergie verte idem
avec votre billet sncf un ter n'aura
évidemment pas la même empreinte qu'un
billet tgv donc en fait on a la
possibilité d'en dire beaucoup plus sur
notre profil à condition de s'y prêter
au jeu parce que ça que ça prend un
petit peu de temps cette appli on le
voit bien là c'est limite mais bon là le
mérite d'exister ce qui est très bien
quel bilan on peut faire aujourd'hui ce
qu'est ce que les particuliers comme
vous y oblige le jeu alors en deux ans
d'existence à la quand même déjà 4
millions d'utilisateurs des utilisateurs
qui petit à petit changent leur
comportement pour preuve ceux qui
l'utilisent une fois par semaine et met
jusqu'à 20% de co2 en moins que ceux qui
se connectent une fois par mois et puis
à noter enfin david greene lee a été élu
fintec de l'année 2020 allez merci
beaucoup et me dit merci c'est la fin de
cette émission pourvu que ça dure les
missions qui rend les co-responsables
sur public sénat mission à voir ou
revoir sur public sénat ou replay sur
publicsenat.fr rendez vous dans deux
semaines
[Musique]